Actually, it very much isn't.
If it's anyone's job to teach sons how to eventually be husbands,
partners, boyfriends,
fathers, it's the dads.
Because no matter what I say as a mother to two sons,
my boys are watching my husband and watching our interactions
and watching how he shows up.
And that is gonna be 10 times more impactful than any sort of, like,
storybook, after school special lesson I could be giving him them.
It always flabbergasts me.
In whatever conversation we're talking about,
we blame the mother because we can't possibly,
as a society, hold men accountable for the circumstances
and the outcomes of their action
or inaction. This is a male issue.
And if you see your son acting up,
it is the father that should be checking him and correcting him.
Let's stop putting all of the labor to raise an entire society
on only mothers. Dads need to step up.
And this is a very good place where they can.
Thank you for coming to my TED talk.